there is a question about whether or not
it's a lifetime appointment i'm not
going to attempt to change that at all
there's some literature among counselors
with scholars about the possibility
of going through one core twitter court
not just always staying the whole time
on the supreme court
but i have made no judgment my word the
words
i've made no judgment they're just a
group of serious conscious or scholars
have a number of ideas how we should
proceed from this point on
and uh that's what we're going to be
doing i'm going to give him a 180 days
god willing if i'm elected
and the time i'm sworn in to be able to
make such a recommendation
to president trump planning an event
outside uh the white house tonight
you know
if you have children raised
all parents are taught that the example
you set
impacts on how your kids react
when you're the boss of an operation the
example you set
you do matters for the rest of the
company
well the words of a president and the
actions of the president
they mattered they matter a great deal
and when the president united states
puts on these super spreader events you
saw what happened when
she was announced all the people
including his family thank god they seem
to be okay
all the people came down with kobe i
just hope
he is willing to have learned a lesson
and there will be significant social
distancing i don't blame him for
celebrating
there's a lot of things we can be doing
having massive crowds
but the fact is that it's just not
appropriate now
and so i just i just hope
he and the vice president others act
with some
dispatch and do it but everybody knows
people should be tested first before
they even show up
number one number two they should be
wearing masks
number three there should be social
existence
number four it shouldn't be a huge crowd
whether it's outside or not
thank you all very good
you're not going to care
you